(sentimental piano music)
- [Narrator] Every year in Haifa,
Israel, a beauty pageant is held.
But the contestants
aren't what you'd expect.
Each is a survivor of the Holocaust.
- [Narrator] But this isn't
a traditional beauty pageant.
Judges consider contestants'
personal stories of survival
and how each has rebuilt their lives
and contributed to their
communities since the war.
- [Narrator] Rita was born in Romania.
In 1942, when she was nine years old,
Nazi soldiers came to her house
and took her father away to be
sent to a concentration camp.
- [Narrator] Rita's father escaped
and survived the war,
but he was badly injured.
The family was eventually reunited
but he never fully recovered
and died just four years later.
Shortly after her father's death,
Rita and her mother sought a fresh start
in the newly-formed country of Israel.
- [Narrator] Since its inception,
the pageant has been controversial.
Some critics claim it sensationalizes
the suffering of the participants.
But Rita doesn't see it that way.
(angelic choir music)